only yesterday on the plane I was going
through my old notes section of my phone
and I found a whole thing on reasons not
to do soap because I always try and find
a reason not to do a job because acting
scares me so much Morris I was in a very
dark place actually it wasn't dark
because what I'd given up I was writing
and producing radio commercials and I
was extremely happy doing it and I
wasn't interested in acting anymore then
my agent who I hadn't spoken to for
months rang and said oh they they want
to see for this Merchant Ivory film and
I said no III can't we bother and my
brother who's a banker and very bossy
who happen to be at home sick that day I
was living with him said don't be
ridiculous you've got to go you need
some money
I'm sick of paying for you so he made me
sort of get dressed up and I went and
and they were kind enough to like me
that was the first sort of propulsion
into movies I I didn't know what to
expect it came out very well people
sometimes say to me are you worried
about playing a gay role and I wasn't at
all Nevernever sort of struck me as if
that was in any way difficult or
dangerous or controversial I remember
the Venice Film Festival the world
premiere of the film I'm sitting next to
James will be and James ivory and
Ishmael merchant in the front row of the
sort of circle and at the end of the
film the audience really loved it and
they stood up and they clapped for a
long time and then the tradition at
Venice is that we the filmmakers stand
up to accept the applause what I had
forgotten is that my suit was much too
tight and I done done it and I'd undone
my trousers quite early in the film and
I completely forgot to do them up so it
did look at that at the end of this gay
film I stand up and bow solemnly to
everyone next to my co-star with my my
trousers undone
for weddings and funerals I got the
script and I thought well there must be
some mistake my agent has sent me a good
script
so I rang him up and I said I think
there's been a mistake you send me a
good script they did that once before
actually with Jerry Maguire and I said I
think there's a mistake here they said
yes sorry that is a mistake that was
meant for Tom Cruise with Four Weddings
it was meant for me it anyway it was
only an audition and I went along and
and I auditioned among the Muppets they
were all around me and I remember I
think he's quite well the director looks
like he likes me but the writer really
hates me that was Richard Curtis and he
admits he did hate me he had a
completely different conception of that
part he'd written it in his own image he
thought it was him and didn't think that
it should be someone who he thought
might get the girl he thought it should
be more like him more kind of nerd issue
them glasses anyway he was he had his
arm twisted and yeah I got the part
the haircut became quite popular yeah
with some I always hated it a haircut on
the clothes the clothes are meant to be
terrible from the haircuts meant to be
terrible shortly before we stopped
shooting that film at one lunchtime they
said okay everyone all the crew into
this room were going to show you some
cut footage of what we've shot so far it
was meant to be morale-boosting
and it played to sepulcro silence
nothing has ever been worse except for
Owens bit
Rowan's bit gonna laugh but the rest of
it was just abominable and we all
trudged back onto the set broken men and
women and we remained in that mood
through finishing the film's through
editing it through the first look at it
we just thought well we're all gonna
have to go and live in Peru and then
they had this screening in Santa Monica
and Los Angeles and the audience loved
it
that's very odd the speech pact was very
much written in convoluted syntax if I
were to ask you could you possibly ever
see your way I mean I'm not saying you
would but if you might to fording in
love with me all that stuff that's what
that's Richard writing that stuff and
then my new orally directed that film
and wanted it even more messed up he
said look I don't you eat a little bit
as a stirrer if you look smooth so you
know mess up the lines and and break
them up and all that so I did all that
and then when that film was was a
success possibly subliminally I let it
bleed into other parts which was a big
say Sense and Sensibility Emma Thompson
adapted Sense and Sensibility to go
Angley to direct it and they offered me
that part and I saw the part of Edward
Ferrars and I said well he's a bit of a
hesitant in love Englishman I don't
think I should do that again and they
said no no we know you can do it very
differently so I said alright then and
then I did exactly the same angley was I
think it was his first non Taiwanese
film he didn't hadn't mastered yet the
art of how to talk to British
insensitive British actors I remember
doing my first scene with them up and I
thought we were marvelous and we went up
to hang after was sitting there at the
monitor he said what you thinking what
you think and he went very boring and
that was very disheartening and he
famously said to Kate Winslet at the end
of her first day of shooting you you
will get better so he was he was scary
but very charming Notting Hill the the
goodwill from Four Weddings was
dissipating fast and Richard wrote this
other film and it was based on us
something he actually happened to a
friend of his who was a kind of very
unfamous
living in Notting Hill who happened to
fall in love with an extremely extremely
world-famous person who I'm not allowed
to mention and she with him so it was
but it was based on that such an obvious
idea for a film I can't believe it's
never been made before and it just just
seemed like it was gonna be dynamite and
then they managed to persuade you know
the then biggest star in the world Julia
Roberts to do it and and then we managed
to not screw it up too badly and he's
you know it was obviously a mega hit at
that moment because it's really properly
romantic and that's the key to his films
they're called romantic comedies and he
actually is funny the jokes are good but
what's special is that they are
genuinely romantic because he's a
romantic
oral Richard it was always in love and
being rejected all that's real rather
than fake as that's kind of Hollywood
romance
[Music]
Bridget Jones's Diary
you know Daniel cleavers quite sort of
West London smooth upper-middle class
come on why they came to me maybe she
thought I was right for it I mean all
all the way through those fluffy films
for wedding is not al it had amused
Richard and his gang his wife everyone
that people thought I was that nice
fluffy character because they knew that
I wasn't I was much closer to for
instance Daniel cleaver so I think it
was fun for them to then slop me into a
role that was closer to the roomie
about a boy it's a novel by Nick Hornby
and a really good one possibly it's
slightly based on himself maybe but I'd
been sort of tracking it for ages and it
was being made by different company and
that director didn't want me and then it
got shifted over to the whites brothers
and I met them and we all got on really
well and they would they were making it
actually with De Niro's company and and
I enjoyed that aspect of it I loved I
loved hanging out with Bob we're going
night clubbing with him I felt very cool
doing that the boy in about a boy needed
to be someone nerdy a loser someone
who's gonna get bullied and we found
Nick and he he was a great actor but he
was too good-looking so we gave him a
[ __ ] haircut terrible clothes but I see
now the dishes triumphed he's a massive
star will in about a boy's Northland and
he's more he's more demotic trendy cool
you know the clothes I had them work
were cool for that period it was it was
a great part and transforming for me and
what I've now realized because you might
not hear it or see it but because I'm
doing an accent in that and really it's
doing a performance that's much further
away from me
it was very releasing and I'm much
better when I'm doing that that's what's
come home to me in the last five years
get away from yourself and I'm actually
better when you're when you're being
someone else moving like them talking
like them
it takes care of the self-consciousness
problem Love Actually well that the
Prime Minister is really again written
rather like Richard Curtis himself and
so when I read this I thought this is
gonna be a huge hit but I don't really
want to be that same character again
I'll get crucified
so I said to Richard you know can't just
be that guy from Notting Hill and from
Four Weddings he said no no it's quite
different you know I'm much tougher and
harder I would write tougher harder yes
yes he is
then then I just did exactly the same
characters the dancing scene was a
terrible cloud hanging over the whole
production for me and you know it's hard
enough to dance if you're English and
middle-aged even with six pints inside
you but by yourself so stone-cold sober
at 7:00 in the morning in front of a
film crew to freak out was gonna be
misery not only that but I thought the
scene had the capacity for being the
most excruciating scene ever committed
to celluloid and there are plenty of
people who still think it is but equally
there lots of people who seem to love it
Cloud Atlas no good no one good its kind
of slightly about reincarnation as I
recall or all my people are vile out of
the blue the very cool witch house keeps
mum wanted me to play five or six parts
in this extraordinary the biggest the
most expensive independent film ever
made I went to meet them to see if it
was some kind of joke on me and it
didn't seem to be and I liked them a lot
so I did it and I you know it was seemed
irresistible to play a cannibal from the
23rd century and then I I thought well
I'm bound to be good at that that's
because that's so fascinating and then I
don't really think about it too much
until I was suddenly on a mountaintop in
Germany with my teeth and my makeup and
my tattoos and I thought I have no idea
how to do this and I had one other which
I was kissing come on man you look at
him like you want you want to [ __ ] to
eat him if I don't have that face give
me a funny line I could do that not sure
I was very good as the cannibal that's
quite good as some of the other parts
and then I think all actors like to be
evil I think because it's it smells true
I've got this horrible feeling I'm 57
that we are evil and that our veneer of
civilized
and niceness is very very thin so when
you're allowed to be your true evil self
it just sort of smells right feels right
it's fun to play in Florence Worcester
Jenkins I am half good half bad I'm a
marvelously supportive husband and sort
of manager to Meryl Streep's
increasingly deranged amateur singer but
you're supposed to think I mean people
didn't think what's his real motive does
he really love her or is he in it for
himself and hopefully people you know
think both simultaneously I certainly
thought he was both which i think is
also very human we can be loving
unselfish and deeply narcissistic and
selfish simultaneously and that was what
he was Errol's a very good singer in
real life and probably that's why she
was able to be bad so well so she would
sing badly and when she first
demonstrated that at one of the
read-throughs you know I just thought
well that's genius and it was incredibly
fun it really makes you laugh but like
all funny things as you repeat them
you know you laugh a little bit less to
be expected she knew that and so
sometimes if I was on camera watching
her and she was off-camera
she'd just dial it up double it to screw
me up make me laugh she was very good at
that actors like playing actors or
people in show business they think this
will be fascinating but actually the
world hates actors quite rightly the key
to that character funnily enough is the
same key to the next film I did
Paddington to narcissism that all
narcissists I don't know why I keep get
her off of these parts but anyway that's
incredibly human that really were just
obsessed with looking out for ourselves
and it was certainly the key to to
Bayfield in Florence Foster Jenkins he's
he was a crap actor the real Bayfield or
at least very moderate very mediocre and
yet dazzled by the limelight the
limelight the limelight and he had
therefore the same disease as poor
forints Worcester Jenkins who was the
world's worst singer just wanted to be
on stage at Carnegie Hall everyone
looking at it do you meet these people
they are very common in life and anyway
so that was definitely the curse of
Buchanan Paddington tune into poor king
who wrote and directed it likes to tell
his story that he wrote a part of him
washed-up narcissistic old actor called
it Hugh and sent it to me first
they dead actually changed the name and
they sent it to me it perhaps that
attacked but nevertheless the letter
that came with the script did say we've
written this narcissistic monster of a
washed-up actor and we thought of you it
was very difficult to get past that
letter but then you know it was a funny
script and I thought I could do that
part that film Paddington you know isn't
there when you're shooting it obviously
because he's created in the computer
afterwards dead you have a choice a
choice every time I was doing a scene
with the bear I could have stick with a
bear's head on the end which was
actually a very sinister thing I didn't
even like looking at it it looked like a
kind of warning to bears don't come into
this area you have your head cut off or
you could have this stand-in lady who
was the same height as Paddington she
was great but that that III ended up
with a stick became quite fond of the
stick Indian Wiest have lunch together a
very English I was about to do something
else I was having dinner with Stephen
Frears one night he said no don't do
that
I got something else and he sent me this
these scripts and I thought television I
don't know television but it was him and
I loved him
we seemed to you know we made a
successful film together it was a it's a
fascinating story it's a very
interesting part of history it's my
childhood the book was brilliant in that
it brought out the black comedy of the
whole thing very mischievous and then
the screenwriter he's extraordinary
Russell T Davis you know he's a proper
genius so I had to say yes in the
courtroom scenes when there's long long
pushings on my face no actor really
likes it because you start well you
think I'm banging character here as the
camera dull is in for 16 bloody hours
you know after sort of 10 seconds you
think I'm slipping out of character or
getting self-conscious and by a minute
into it you know what's happened to my
jaw I can't even feel it anymore
actors decide to do jobs for various
reasons but I think the two main ones
is it a very fascinating and showy role
for them and the other one is will this
thing work but I've always been
absolutely fixated on will it also be an
entertaining thing because if not this
is a wank what's the point of it so for
me this one had both I thought people
are definitely going to enjoy this
because it's such a weird story it's
just sort of tragic and repulsive and it
at the same time funny and equally this
is a great part you know he was a man
who's I sort of knew the breed my mother
was at Oxford in the 50s and the friends
she'd made there used to come to dinner
sometimes when I was a kid and they were
very Jeremy Thorpe very smooth charming
and reptilian so I knew that breed and
then here was this sort of epitome of
the one of those guys with all this not
just dark secrets and and a weird sort
of nasty narcissistic side but also
tragedy
Jeremy thought was never able to be
himself never able to love someone in
his own way which happened to be gay and
that's deeply tragic you know that was
that's that's one of his tragedies and
then his other tragedy as a more sort of
classic Greek or Shakespearean one which
is that one event in his life gradually
brings him down
having built himself up to with a
terrific career and life reputation this
thing just destroyed
[Music]